daredevil season one is currently
available on Netflix and excuse my voice
not being up to par I'm getting over a
cold as I said in my previous video
about Jared Leto's Joker I apologize I'm
going to struggle through this let's do
this
daredevil fucking awesome show holy shit
so guys if you watch the 2003 film
daredevil starring Ben Affleck and you
are fans of the man with no fear then
you were probably vastly disappointed as
I was it was a movie that when I was
younger I was like it's okay it's kind
of cool and then when you watch it now
as an adult you're like why aren't his
legs broken when he jumps a hundred feet
into the air isn't he a human but in
this show Charlie Cox plays Matthew
Murdock a blind lawyer by day and a
vigilante by night because of an
accident when he was a child he has
heightened senses he's able to walk into
a room and visually see in his head the
various things that are going on through
tiny vibrations in the air he can hear
people's heartbeats to tell when they're
lying or telling the truth
this guy has superhuman senses but he is
actually just a man which makes his
exploits as daredevil so entertaining
because technically like on paper he's a
superhero but he's just a guy who has
these abilities and who's trying to make
a difference he is basically Marvel's
version of Batman except he's not rich
and he's blind and he has the heightened
senses and all that stuff but he is
essentially Batman at night now when I
saw the first image released of
daredevil in his costume I thought it
looked cheap I thought this is going to
be horrible this show is gonna suck I
will not watch it I was very wrong this
is one of the best things Marvel's ever
done daredevil is a show that similar to
The Dark Knight trilogy doesn't tell a
superhero story it's really telling a
realistic crime drama in fact the
creator's even said their first priority
was to tell a very good crime saga not
to make a superhero show and that's one
of the reasons this show succeeds so
well because you have very grounded and
realistic characters that feel like
they're inhabiting a real world and
since you have this entire season to
tell Daredevils origin story you're able
to flesh out these characters so much
and the relationships that form between
Matthew Murr
doc and his partner foggy Nelson and a
girl named Karen who works there firm
that they're just like starting up all
these relationships are so entertaining
and create real human beings and so you
can really care when he dons his black
mass and starts beating people up at
night now about that costume I've heard
people that I specifically know in real
life tell me that costume looks way too
cheap I'm not going to watch the show
I'm like look have you ever read the man
with no fear by Frank Miller so many
comic book adaptations now are taking
inspiration from Frank Miller but this
show is very dark in that way but not
dark in a sense where it's all dark and
gritty and everything has to be dark and
gritty and old boo hoo and we're sad
this is an extremely fun show actually
that exists in a real world and that's
what I mean by gritty Hell's Kitchen as
depicted in this show is a nasty
disgusting place and even the people who
want to live there who feel good about
their city are still afraid to walk in
certain areas so the characters are well
realized it tells a beautiful origin
story it also has a lot of humor to it
which I was very surprised by let's talk
about the action sequences particularly
episode 2 and I'm not going to spoil the
technique if you haven't heard of it yet
because someone did that for me guys
this is action done right every problem
I've had with action movies today is
solved in the show with realistic combat
good stunts and very good camerawork I
was so pleased to see all of that
throughout this show despite the fact
that it looked so low-budget at first
this is actually a gorgeous-looking show
with excellent performances from Charlie
Cox and rosario Dawson it goes back and
forth between when he was young and when
he was older which fleshes out that
character even more you see him as a
youngster with his dad who's a boxer you
figure out how he became the way he is
you understand why he has certain
priorities in his life and it's told
wonderfully now I haven't mentioned one
of the best aspects of the show and that
is Vincent D'Onofrio as the kingpin
Wilson Fisk I hope I said his name
correctly his performance is that kind
of performance that's right on the edge
of possibly being awful but just on the
edge to the point where it's brilliant
there's an entire episode dedicated to
his childhood as well as a romance with
him throughout the show that is able to
explore his humanity
he's not just some evil guy who sits on
a big chair who commands his various
cronies to do things for him this is a
human being and the show very wisely
explores why he has the thought process
that he has these are the best villains
the villains that you can actually
understand because you can watch the
show and you can see him do these
various atrocities and yet you
understand his viewpoint and his
thinking for everything he's doing
you're not condoning it but you
understand why he thinks it's right and
that is brilliant storytelling guys
daredevil has a great hero great
performances a great villain good action
and realistic fight scenes as well as
fleshed out characters and it takes the
origin of daredevil makes it make sense
makes it awesome and it gets you pumped
up for more I can't wait to see more of
daredevil I'm looking forward to season
two and I highly recommend that you guys
check this out it is one of the best
things that Marvel has ever made and I'm
going to give daredevil season 1 and a
guys I strongly suggest checking the
show out it is definitely worth your
time it is so much fun and I hope they
take some of the characters even further
throughout season 2 also guys I want to
let you know that my promotion with
audible.com is continuing if you go to
audible.com slash Chris you can download
any audiobook you want for free my gift
to you guys no strings attached I'm
literally running a promotion with
audible to give you guys free audiobooks
if you would like one it's pretty cool
they have all the Star Wars novels on
audible.com which is something I'm
really enjoying the new Lords of the
Sith novels coming out very soon I'm
looking forward to checking that one out
actually got that book at the Star Wars
Celebration but the audiobook for that's
going to be available as well as tons of
other Star Wars novels that's
audible.com slash Kris a free audio book
of your choice a lot of you guys have
thanked me for that one person in
particular needed a study book that he
couldn't get at school because he didn't
have the money for it but audible.com
had it so you guys can go to audible.com
slash Kris and download any audio book
of your choice for free my gift to you
thank you so much as always for watching
guys and let me know if you watched
daredevil season one because
definitely worth your time and it
doesn't have bullseye launching a peanut
into an old lady's throat Jennifer
Garner has Electra jumping like 200 feet
in the air guys thank you so much as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get steppen
eyes